the legendary North American Esports org
TSM has just made its triumphant return
to CS go for the first time since 2017
and they did it in the most North
American way possible by signing a fully
European team
[Music]
yes the news is true TSM has announced
their return to CS go with a brand new
roster this one of the other than hiding
inside the smoke he might be a genius
he's still baiting them out continuing
on top what a God that's gotta be the
most perfectly played round I have ever
seen now why is this such a joyous
occasion well less than a month ago we
didn't even think this [__] team was
going to make it off the ground we have
known for quite some time now about
tsm's return to Counter-Strike in fact
we knew it was going to be a European
roster and exactly who was going to be
on it we also knew that the team was
going to play in their first event at
the beginning of August however that
never happened according to French
reporters there were verbal breaches
from the organization meaning TSM
allegedly went back on their agreement
to pay coach xtaz for the work he did
helping build the team the headlines
were looking pretty dire and the fact
that they missed their first event
wasn't looking good either and it's also
TSM literally the worst outcome is
always a possibility thankfully a
miracle must have happened because an
agreement was met and the roster remains
100 intact boy oh boy it's an
interesting roster on paper these guys
have depth a veteran igl and Coach two
Young Guns a cracked Russian a hot guy
it's giving real 2017 CS go Vibes and
honestly feels like a mouse sports team
but nonetheless I'm excited xtazz needs
no introduction as the former coach of
G2 and vitality same goes with valday
2018 hltv top 20 who grew to become a
promising igl for North enters is
another great addition sure his
controversial benching from Cloud9 might
have been due to his lacking performance
but for a period of time he was one of
the best anchors in the game if he can
get back to that level of play TSM has a
very powerful rifler on their hands up
next are the two 20 year olds Moto and
Cipher Now Moto is coming in as a rookie
so I can't say too much about him but
Cipher is a dude who's been on my list
for quite some time now ever since his
standout performance at the Paris major
Cipher has been on everybody's radar and
for good reason at a young age he
already has a very big personality and
thanks to how aggro in game he is he can
back it up too and he's getting
edged on backup and he will not be there
in time siphon with the jewel he's now
one versus two trying to hunt them down
oh they're staying here he should be
dead when he hits the headshot coming
back
no way he's taken the last one down into
the breach a shocking the Counter-Strike
World rounding out the team is another
Frenchman Jax who is probably the most
interesting choice on this roster now
I'm not saying Jax is a slouch in fact
I've long believed that he's better than
what he gets credit for but when you
play for a team like G2 it's easy to go
unnoticed that being said he is in his
30s now and it will be interesting to
see what role he plays on the team at
the very least I assume he'll be that
veteran presence the young players need
it's long been reported that Jax is one
of the funniest and kindest players in
the game and honestly maybe that's what
the team needs especially when they
start out the only question now is when
does TSM play well so far we don't have
a concrete answer but I will say that
it's pretty much too late for any big
event this year Pro leagues already
underway and they missed the qualifying
for Sydney so we might be waiting until
next year this means that TSM could be
starting in CS2 which would be super
exciting you know if the game actually
comes out now with that said said there
are a bunch of smaller events like rubat
cup that I could see them playing in
although debuting in 2024 with the
release of CS2 would be pretty cool it's
probably best for the boys to start
playing as soon as possible regardless
of when that is I'm pretty excited it's
always cool to see OG orgs come back to
the game and honestly the black and
white has always been pretty sexy plus
the team at the very least is going to
be entertaining now with all good news
comes the bat and in regards to TSM CS
go they are obviously no longer North
American as I said we've known for quite
some time now that the team was going to
be European but it just sucked to see
yet another historic n a org make the
jump and for TSM League of Legends fans
who may be watching could this be a
major clue as to where the team will end
up after their departure from the LCS if
their CS team is now European it
wouldn't be that surprising if their
league team ends up in the same place
now sure when TSM first came to CS go it
was the Danish boys that would one day
become astralis but after that TSM
became a breeding ground for fantastic
North American talent twists sick Shazam
automatic any Legends cut their teeth on
TSM yes it all ended in Flames with you
guessed it Reggie causing everyone to
leave the team in solidarity with Sean
Garris but it was fun while it lasted
and I can't help but feel a bit
disappointed with that said I'm sure
many of you are looking forward to
seeing this team in action with their EU
counterparts however since this is once
again TSM we're talking about will they
actually be able to last or are they
just going to crash and burn over silly
drama like every roster before them
I have a prediction
I think this roster is going to be okay
I think they're going to make the first
major and CS2
and I think
they will
make it out of groups but then
immediately lose after that that is my
bold prediction you can come back to
this video and make fun of me if I'm
wrong but that's what I think they're
going to make the first CS2 major
and make it past groups and that is it